how do you make the right choice when
buying a new macbook well we've been
testing each one of these for at least a
few months and in this video i will make
it extremely simple to make the correct
choice saving you hundreds or even
thousands of dollars apple has finally
transitioned all of their laptops to
their own apple silicon chips and these
machines are amazing they run cooler and
quieter than the intel models they
replace while having more performance
and better battery life and in many
cases they cost less while having more
features these macs start from 9.99 all
the way up to 3 500 and if you spec them
out one can reach up to 6
100
which you definitely shouldn't do so
i'll tell you which upgrades are worth
getting and which ones you should avoid
to get the best value most of these
configurations are also available on
amazon with shipping times that are
faster and prices that are lower than
from apple for example this macbook air
is just 899
and i've seen it as low as 850 so we'll
go ahead and link the best deals down in
the video description below and now
let's compare literally everything
between these macs with real world
results and scenarios instead of just
spec sheets to help you guys make the
best informed choice that's gonna
actually make a difference in the real
world let's start with portability if
you want an ultra portable mac the
macbook air is by far the best being
only 2.8 pounds and it's also the only
one with a wedge shape so it feels
thinner than the rest the 13 inch
macbook pro isn't much heavier than the
air but the new 14 inch definitely is
but it is still manageable if you need
the extra features now the 16 inch was
always the biggest but with the new
redesign it gained the most weight
compared to the other one and it comes
in up to 4.8 pounds and even though i've
always owned larger macbooks it is now
over the top for me to use and carry
with me daily on the go so unless you
need some of its few key advantages and
features that i will talk about in just
a bit i would avoid it unless you don't
care about portability now if you're
somebody that does a lot of typing these
are all great machines since they all
have the updated magic keyboards but one
thing i would keep in mind is that the
thicker the machine the more the edge of
the mat can dig into your wrist so if
you do a lot of typing the macbook air
is king because its wedge shape allows
the front edge to be ultra thin and
super comfortable now for those that
mostly use the touch pad the 16 inch
does have the largest one which is great
for gestures but in our use we didn't
really have problems even with the
smallest one which is in the macbook air
as far as ports the macbook air and the
13-inch macbook pro have the same two
thunderbolt ports on the left side and a
headphone jack on the right now for most
people these are enough but sometimes if
you're trying to charge and connect
multiple accessories you could be in a
tough situation so if you're buying one
of these macs i would suggest buying an
inexpensive multi-port adapter which
will give you extra ports along with a
card reader and hdmi the new 14 and 16
inch macbooks on the other hand brought
back a bunch of ports like dedicated
magnetic magsafe charging which can
charge your mac faster and it doesn't
use up one of the thunderbolt ports all
while disconnecting if somebody yanks or
trips on the cable with that you get
three thunderbolt ports instead of two
and they are more powerful so if you
hook up to docs they could basically
become up to 12. you also get a fast sd
card reader and an hdmi 2 port built in
where most of the third-party cheaper
accessories for macbooks have less
capable connections that are slower so
in the real world having these extra
ports are really nice but the big
question is if it's worth spending way
more money for the 14-inch macbook to
not have to use dongles well personally
i would not make that jump unless you
need one of the few other exclusives
that come with those more expensive macs
so let's keep going on with the
differences if you're somebody who wants
to connect to external displays this is
one big difference between the 13 inch
macbooks and the 14 or 16 inch the
cheaper m1 max can only support one
external display whereas the m1 pro max
can support up to 2 or if you upgrade to
the m1 max chip which is only available
on the larger max you can connect up to
four displays now most people don't need
to connect four displays but we found
that one can be a limitation for power
users so two is a real good sweet spot
next let's talk about the built-in
displays apple makes a huge deal about
their new xdr displays in the 14 and 16
inch macbooks but how much does it
really matter in the real world well
these screens are really nice but i
think that for most people it's not as
big of a deal as apple would want you to
believe for one even though they can
reach a peak brightness of 1600 nits
most of the time they will stay at the
same maximum brightness of 500 just like
the 13 inch macbook pro now the macbook
air is the only one that maxes out at
400 nits but in the real world we found
that it's not as huge of a difference as
you would think because of apple's
really good anti-reflectivity coatings
the new xdr screens only go above 500
nits with hdr content like if you're
watching or editing hdr videos or photos
so if you work with hdr you have to get
the new more expensive macs but most
people don't do that and apart from hdr
they all have the same color accuracy
and excellent real world display
sharpness i will say that the larger
screens are nicer for productivity
especially for video editing so if you
can handle a 16 inch the screen size
really helps but for most things the 14
inch is a really nice compromise with
that if you watch a lot of videos and
movies the xdr screen is a massive step
up for hdr and i would absolutely push
myself to buy a 14 inch or a 16 inch
with the 16 inch being preferred for
movies especially if you want to use the
built-in speakers so let's go ahead and
take a listen to our speaker comparison
bring me back
the 14 inch and 16 inch models have six
speakers with dedicated woofers that
sound noticeably better than the 13-inch
models with that said the air sounds
slightly better than the pro and the
cheaper macbook still sound better than
most windows laptops the 14-inch is just
as loud as the 16 inch but what most
people don't know is that the 16 inch
has much deeper bass which is better for
movies and music so if you care about
having the best speakers the 16 inch is
the way to go but the 14 inch sounds
awesome now as far as webcams and
microphones both the 13-inch macbooks
feature 720p webcams and the 13-inch
macbook air is the only mac that is not
labeled as having studio quality
microphones and this is the 13 inch
macbook pro so you guys let me know do
the studio microphones make a noticeable
difference and the new 14 and 16 inch
macbook pros both feature the same 1080p
webcams with new larger sensors for
better quality so if you need the best
quality webcams those are the macs that
you should get as far as battery life we
do have some differences between these
machines but all of them are phenomenal
compared to older intel macs and each
one can get you through a full day of
use the best one is the 16-inch macbook
pro followed by the 13-inch pro just
because they have larger batteries
compared to their power usage now the
13-inch air and the 14-inch pro are
behind but still excellent and the only
one that is a bit disappointing is if
you get the 14-inch with the best m1 max
chip because of how much power it uses
in general if you want the best battery
life you will want to stick with the
base processors for each macbook but
also keep in mind that all of these
systems can be powered with a cheap usb
type-c power bank so if you need the
best performance or really long battery
life with a smaller machine i'll just go
ahead and link that down below and now
let's get into performance which is
where we have so many different options
with different systems different
upgrades and i'm going to get into all
of that and make it very easy for you
first off i want to be honest and say
that for most people the m1 macbook air
is more than enough now sure it is
tempting to buy the latest and greatest
but even the fanless m1 macbook air
smoke my fifteen thousand dollar mac pro
and many tests and destroyed last year's
macbook pro in most cpu tasks so for
most of you do not feel like you need to
buy an m1 pro or an m1 max equipped
macbook just because you do photo or
video editing and even though the
macbook air is fanless and can slow down
in benchmarks we found that in real
world use the difference was very
minimal even under extreme loads and
didn't warrant the extra 300
for the better cooled macbook pro i'll
just come out and say it right now i do
not think that anybody should be buying
the 13 inch macbook pro the air is just
so close in performance even with the
base 7 core gpu and the rest of the
specs are so close now that you're
literally wasting hundreds of dollars
with very little real world difference
now the 14 and 16 inch macbook pros
start with m1 pro processors that have
either six or eight performance cords
instead of four with m1 but for most
regular tasks you will not notice the
difference since single core speeds are
so close and most software is so well
optimized for those that need extra cpu
performance for things like coding music
production or photo editing the m1 pro
chips definitely offer that and the 14
inch can have the same 10 core m1 pro
processor if you spend an extra 2 or 300
more for a cpu upgrade the only downside
is that the base 14 inch and the base 16
inch both run almost silently but if you
upgrade the 14 inch to the same cpu as
the base 16 inch comes with for 2500 you
start hearing the fan more often and the
battery life goes down and you're also
only 200 away from a 16-inch model the
other question is if the extra
performance is worth it for that upgrade
technically it's a good value for the
extra money that you're spending but for
me personally unless you're going to
spend
way more money for an m1 max upgrade i
would just stick to the base 14-inch cpu
because it's already extremely fast
while staying cool and quiet now in my
opinion where the 14 and 16 inch
macbooks are really worth it over the 13
inch m1 macbook is graphics performance
the m1 will work for most people even if
you do some video editing but if you
work with long projects or heavy effects
where you do 3d work or your game the
extra graphics performance is invaluable
for the vast majority of people the 14
core or 16 core graphics in the m100 pro
will be enough but if you know you're
going to really push your graphics with
8k or high-end animations or you just
want the best performance the m1 max
comes in costing way more money but
offering a lot of performance now it
also allows up to four displays to be
used like i mentioned before and for
video editors if you want to export
video super quickly the dual encoders
export video much faster than the m1 pro
or the m1 which they perform about the
same the one thing i will note is that
if you want the full 32 core m1 max you
should get a 16 inch macbook pro because
the 14 inch model gets too hot and the
32 core barely performs better than the
24 core option which is 200 less while
using way more battery so if you're
buying a 14 inch macbook do not go
higher than the 24 graphic scores while
in a 16 inch i would say spend the extra
money if you're already spending that
much and buy the full 32 core
configuration that also brings us to
memory we have done a ton of
side-by-side real-world ram tests and to
make it short and simple for 99 of you i
would buy the base ram configurations
that come with the machines even if you
think you need a lot of ram the only
time i would upgrade from 8 gigabytes to
16 gigabytes in an m1 is if you want to
use virtual machines or if you use a ton
of plugins in logic for the 14 and 16
inch macbooks i would only jump up to 32
gigabytes if you are getting an m1 max
chip which forces you to upgrade anyways
apart from that apple silicon is so good
and mac os is so efficient that you are
just wasting money and if you don't
believe me make sure just to go and
watch those videos as far as storage for
most simple use base amounts with these
machines work well but if you know you
like to keep a lot of local apps files
or projects i would bump it up one step
or two at most going above that costs a
lot more money and the bang for the buck
goes down so much and fast external
drives are now so cheap same thing with
cloud storage i would not spend that
much money unless you really don't care
about value which in that case you
shouldn't be watching this video just
buy the best one overall i would highly
recommend the macbook air to most people
even for those that do some productivity
and i would tell most not to buy the 13
inch macbook pro the base 14 inch is the
best machine for those that value
portability and want the advanced
features or need extra graphics
performance the 16 inch base model is
the best value for the money if you are
mostly performance or multimedia focused
and if you want to push performance even
further the 16 inch will still give you
a good bang for the buck and it won't
thermal throttle or lose too much
battery while staying decently quiet now
if you start upgrading a 14 inch model
that is the worst value in my opinion
but for a select small group of people
that need something that is very
portable while at the same time being
very powerful only apple offers
something as this performance in this
package with this battery life so
although it is a poor value relative to
the macbook lineup it is still something
that is offered and if you don't mind
that then it is there so there you guys
go hopefully this video made it
extremely clear to you which macbook is
right for you and which upgrades are
worth it and which ones to avoid if you
enjoyed it click that circle above to
subscribe and help us reach our goal of
a million subscribers check out one of
those great comparisons right over there
and we have a ton of them if you do a
lot of other productivity search up max
tech and whichever mac you're interested
in you'll see it thanks for watching and
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you